Yeah.
The day I laid,
um,
well in part I laid a list of pro slavery arguments are on you and a lot of
quotations to give you a sense of the depth and breadth of pro slavery ideology.
I didn't want to leave that entirely without tying up or not or to
just consider this as a sense of the scale of pro slavery writing.
I don't want anybody to think that
one slave holding politicians,
when the planter elite of the American south begins to organize toward at least
toward some kind of separation in succession over this slave society.
They want to protect.
They are reading hundreds and hundreds of pages
about their system.
In 1855 and anthology of pro-slavery writings was published in the south.
There was about 450 pages long in 1860 that anthology was updated,
particularly with the words of George fits you into a 900 page volume,
which was really in most ways only excerpts of pro-slavery writing
and it was a work on the desks of most secessionist.
I also didn't want to leave you thinking this was all about
abstract ideology.
One of the best descriptions I've ever read
and why slavery persisted of why people defended it and why people went to war
for it came before the war in 1857 in the speech by the African American woman,
novelist,
writer,
Poet Francis Ellen Watkins Harper,
and an 1850 antislavery speech.
She said,
among other things,
this conclusion,
in fact,
she's answering the question now,
why has slavery boomed and persisted in and grows still?
And this is in the wake of the dred Scott decision.
Ask Marilyn.
She says,
whether 10,000 with her tens of thousands of slaves.
If she is not prepared for freedom and hear her answer,
I help supply the coffles gangs to the south as Virginia where there are
hundreds of thousands of slaves if she is not weary with her merchandise,
a blood and anxious to shake the gory traffic from her hands.
And here her reply though fertility has covered my soul.
This is Virginia speaking.
Though I hold in my hand or wealth of power enough to turn the spindles to close
the world.
Yet,
one of my chief staples has been the sons and daughters I sent to the human
markets as farther south.
And all the cotton growing states chime in.
We have need of fresh supplies to fill the ranks of those whose lives have gone
out and unrequited toil and our distant plantations.
100,000 newborn babies are annually added to the victims of slavery,
said Fran and Francis Ellen Watkins,
Harper,
20,000 lives or annually sacrificed.
And the plantations of the Sao such a site should send a thrill of a horror
through the nerves of civilization and impel the heart of humanity to lofty
deeds.
So it might,
if men had not found,
oh and here's her phrase worth remembering,
a fearful alchemy by which this blood can be transformed and the gold,
instead of listening to the cry of agony,
they listened to the ring of dollars and stoop down and pick up the coins.
Uh,
fearful alchemy.
That's a useful definition of slavery.
Why did it in humane institution?
Of course not everybody who defended and thought it was inhumane,
but why did that systems survive?
Persists.
It's him grow.
Cause it was so damned profitable.
Last time I began with Alexander H.
Stevens,
famous cornerstone speech and 1861 famous passage by the vice president,
the confederacy,
declaring slavery,
the cornerstone of the confederate movement.
We'd go north.
Today we're going to look largely at the nature of northern society.
We're going to look to some extent today and mostly next Tuesday at the roots
and origins of an antislavery ideology of growing antislavery out ideology.
And it's many layered forms.
But I want to begin today with another passage
from the warriors and ask now from a northern point of view,
how do we get to Uriah parmelee now there is a 19th century name for you.
Nobody's named Uriah anymore.
You know any of your Riaz.
Hmm.
Uriah Parmalee
was a kid who grew up on a Connecticut farm.
The Best I've been able to determine.
His family was part of this market revolution.
They ended up moving to a small town,
are no longer engaged in subsistence agriculture if his parents had or his,
and by means,
I don't entirely understand your parmelee.
In the spring of 1861
was an abolitionist.
It was a junior at Yale College.
Okay.
He'd gotten caught up and abolitionism an anti slavery.
I was young.
People get caught up in political fervor and movements of their times sometimes.
Okay.
As soon as the civil war broke out in Lincoln call for volunteers and late
April,
1861 Uriah permanently dropped out of his junior year at Yale and he joined the
first regimen he could get into.
There wasn't one organizing it around new haven or nearby in Connecticut,
so he went to New York and he joined the sixth New York cavalry
to his brother.
Permanently confided.
I am more of an abolitionist than ever now,
right up to the handle.
If I had money enough to raise a few hundred contrabands and arm them,
I'd get up and insurrection among the slaves.
Told the captain I had dessert to do it.
Nah,
a lot of Chutzpah.
That passage,
he hasn't seen any real war yet.
He wants to be John Brown at that point.
He's going to get him stuff with band of insurrection isn't going on here and
kills them.
Slave holders.
He says
Parmalee and letters back home to his parents,
his brothers,
his sisters,
and he wrote lots of them.
He at first denounce Lincoln's government for its failure in 1861 and
[inaudible] early 80 62 to come out against slavery to make it a war against
slavery.
Okay?
He denounces the government.
He's serving in a letter in late 1861 from the front.
The president contest,
he says,
will indeed subtle the question for some years at least as to where the union,
our succession,
the constitution or rebellion shall triumph.
But the great heart wound,
slavery,
well not be reached.
Yeah,
he's angry.
He's pissed off.
He wants the war to be against slavery
and it's not.
He goes on and a letter,
and in spring 1862 the war still isn't a war against slavery in any official
sense.
And he writes on his brother's saying he wishes he had the quote,
moral courage to dessert because he no longer wants to serve this car,
but he doesn't dessert.
By March,
1863 he had concluded that emancipation would indeed be achieved.
This is now in the wake of Congress's confiscation accident 62 Lincoln's
preliminary proclamation,
the ultimate emancipation proclamation as of January,
1863 and by march of that Spring,
he's convinced the war has transformed.
He refused a furlough to stay and fight.
He rides home.
I do not intend to shirk now that there is really something to fight for.
I mean freedom since the 1st of January.
It has become more and more evident to my mind that the war is henceforth to be
conducted upon a different basis.
Those who profess to love the union or not so anxious to preserve slavery.
While those who are opposed to the war knowledge and all their actions that its
continuance.
We'll put an end to this,
a curse it system so then I am willing to remain and endure whatever may fall to
mindshare.
He was honored for bravery by at least three commanding officers in numerous
battles,
especially the battle of Chancellorsville in May of 1863 he was promoted to
captain.
Eventually a switched his New York Raj.
This happened to many regimens in the civil war.
Took so many casualties.
It ceased to exist and he switched to a Connecticut Regiment and he served that
Connecticut regimen through the summer of 1864.
The Great War of attrition in Virginia.
He survived the battle of the wilderness,
the battle of Spotsylvania courthouse,
Battle of cold harbor,
the entire siege of Petersburg from August of 64 all the way until the end of
March of 1865.
Okay.
He was killed on April 1st,
1865 at the battle of five oaks of,
of uh,
excuse me,
at five forks just west of Richmond,
the last major engagement of the civil war.
And when you walk out today and you go through Woolsey Hall,
if you haven't done this before,
you'll note if you haven't before that that's full of the names of El College
man who died in war.
And Uriah Parma Lee's name.
We'll be right on your right as you're walking through these,
this high on my arm or shoulder.
And there's his name dropped out junior year to fight to destroy slavery.
And he did for four years and died in the last battle.
But how do you get to your riot?
Parmelee
a kid from Connecticut,
obviously bright enough or connected enough to get into Yale,
gave all that up for something he saw as a lot higher.
If you can come to understand a Uriah parmelee or better yet,
if you can come to understand young white,
northern Yankee,
Anglo Saxon Protestants,
who often were very contemptuous of Irish immigrants and even more contemptuous,
a black Americans who nevertheless believed the war of 1861 had to be fought and
ultimately came even to support the destruction of slavery.
If you can understand why those northern Yankees get to that point,
you really will understand the civil war.
Uriah parmelee had an inheritance.
What level?
He exactly understood it.
I can't necessarily know about his letters are extraordinarily rich.
No.
In that northern society and here we're using labels pretty loosely,
but so be it.
The northern states and,
well,
I'll leave the outline up for the moment.
No,
I won't
use,
I'm told I have to.
I can brighten that apparently.
Whoops,
that's clapper.
It's a wonderful painting of a,
oops,
I didn't do it.
Live it.
Huh?
What a
wonderful painting from meeting 30 called the Yankee peddler was hurting Yankee
peddler's.
It'll come door to door anymore unless they're working for the Jehovah's
Witnesses.
Oops.
Well,
or the,
um,
environmental action committee or the,
uh,
let's see.
Nevermind
what the voice of what's the Yankee peddler peddler cloth.
Readymade factory made cloth for a woman,
a housewife who isn't making her own cloth anymore.
That's the market revolution in a thousand ways to see it,
understand it,
grasp it.
If the south was a slave society and we tried to demonstrate that last time we
tried to,
um,
define that,
although it's not defined in that newspaper that you're reading back there in
row 12 marketing revolution is not reported in this morning's newspaper.
Actually.
It probably is.
The markets are going bad,
although they went back up yesterday.
But this market revolution is not reported in that newspaper.
I would venture,
sorry to interrupt you,
but it was,
the south was a slave society.
The North was a market society.
It was a booming market society by the 1820 [inaudible] and 1830s.
It was beginning to be a market society.
Even the late 18th century,
the northern states by the antebellum period,
1820s thirties 1840s was beginning to sort of hurdle toward a different future
than what that slave society was perhaps.
No,
not really.
Slowly two is hurtling toward a certain future.
This market,
this booming market society with its market,
commercial consumerist mentalities,
and it's,
it's belief.
Eventually it's faith in its defense of free labor for the common man.
It's kind of fanfare for the common man.
Etiology would be something a lot of white southerners.
Okay.
Would actually fear and be frightened by what is the market revolution.
It's the time in which it's not a single moment in time.
Of course,
it's a long process,
but it's the time in which long distance commerce began to take hold because of
transportation,
revolutions,
canals,
roads,
railroads in particular.
It's a time of technological innovation,
tremendous technological innovation.
So much technological change that half the time it frightened people.
If how you can find all over,
we're American culture in 1800 1810 even into the 1820s a lot of fear of tech.
No.
What is this thing?
A telegraph
that today you probably don't fear technology.
I still have a little bit of there.
I'm still a little 19th century in that sentence.
I hate it when they tell me they want to buy me a new laptop.
Enough already care.
If it's four years old and I want another one,
don't make me learn something new with my machines.
Okay.
The market revolution was driven of course by the growth of cities,
which became market centers and manufacturing centers.
Maybe more importantly,
the market revolution is that time in American history.
That incredible time really when you think about the scale of change
when 18th century subsistence farmers who engaged in what was always called or
we've always called mixed agriculture that is that right?
All kinds of food stuffs almost always for themselves.
When that kind of 18th century style farming gave way to commercial farming or
farmers now produced cash crops for a much broader market,
a market on the east coast,
if they were in upstate new or out in Ohio eventually and a market of the whole
world.
It's that period when the home or the farm.
Still a majority of northern people buy the 18,018 Ford.
We're making their livings from agriculture,
but it's a time when that home and farm became its own domestic factory
or people began to produce in their homes for markets,
not for themselves.
The vast multitude were still farmers,
but they began to now buy goods,
manufactured goods,
readymade clothing and shoes,
cloth candles,
soap,
all kinds of food stuffs,
stuff that the 18th century farm made for him and herself.
Now
you bought from a peddler or you bought from a store in town.
This all course leads to a change in what European history has taught us to call
mentalities mentality.
It brought about fundamental alteration slowly in ways.
Sometimes people never know it's happening.
Fundamental alterations in aspirations,
in habits and activities,
in conceptions and definitions of work and leisure.
What is work and leisure now in a society where you don't have to produce
everything for yourself,
okay?
It produced,
it would produce fundamental alterations in the conception of labor.
Who's the worker?
What is Labor?
Is the labor anymore Justin individual or as a labor part of a collective
problem,
part of a collective mentality,
part of a collective movement against a much greater force now called capital
manufacturing is our company.
It's going to alter the very idea of individual rights.
We have a habit in this society to think that individual rights when when,
when they,
when they drafted the bill of rights was just laid down for us and it's just
travel through time and here they are.
Just go back and look at the founders.
It's such nonsense.
It's a historical,
the very idea of individual rights got reshaped by the market revolution.
What do you have a right to know
new shoes?
It's going to change the very idea of mobility.
Where can you go and how by what means it's going to really change and this is
absolutely crucial indirectly in helping us understand this war that's going to
come down the way
it's going to change for a lot of northern millions of northern people.
Some of them now,
immigrants who have come here with a clear purpose and as the makeup better
life,
it's going to change their conception of what they can give the children
and we're gonna hear a lot more later on next week,
week after about free Labor ideology.
Yeah,
I do.
That of labor is left free then that common man always has a chance if the land
isn't taken up by the large oligarchies like slave hope.
I slave holding class and I'm the small guy has a chance but rooted in free
Labor ideology is among other ideas,
this notion of mobility that are free labor is a mobile labor,
especially in a society like the United States that had this thing called the
West,
the limitless apparently to them anyway,
boundless West,
even such concepts,
such great American concepts,
let's call it that as self-reliance about which Ralph Waldo Emerson may have
written his greatest essay.
I go,
I go read Emerson and self reliance of at least once a year just,
I don't know the field better or something.
It's the quintessential sort of expression of individualism,
but it's more than that.
But even an idea like self reliance,
I can remake my world,
I can be anything I want is changed by the market revolution.
It doesn't mean people believe any lesson in self reliance.
It's just the keep seeing evidence.
They keep bumping into realities of the show them that in the face of the market
now especially the boom and bust cycles of the market,
their individualism is not so powerful.
A market revolution would on the level of ideas and thinking and sort of common
behavior would bring about a kind of combination of tremendous optimism
possibly like we've never experienced sin so that you can find other moments in
American history like the 1950s um,
where a kind of broad bra social optimism took hold of Americans.
It's one of the reasons we had a civil rights movement,
but at the same time a market revolution is going to bring a certain sense of
anxiety,
even dread,
even despair.
It will also,
it will lead to great wealth.
Of course,
fortunes will begin to be made and the textile industry and in the railroad
industry by the forties and fifties and in a host of other ways,
real fortunes and some fortunes will begin to be made in simple financial
speculation.
Wall Street will be born at the same time,
of course,
as well as the inequality in wealth grows too.
Specialization will set in workplaces that some,
you know,
the,
that your parent's generation may have grown up understanding as a very personal
place.
Even if you worked in a small shop,
you know,
they only had eight workers and you were related to half of them.
The workplace would become less personal,
bigger,
uncontrollable women went to work most famously in the low factories in
Massachusetts and in other places.
MMM.
Among the many images
of
the famous mill girls is this one taken an 1850 I believe in Lowell,
Massachusetts.
She looks about nine years old.
She may have been 12 or 13 both fee,
but for the first time in significant numbers,
young girls and young women left farm,
left around of domesticity,
left that world in which they presumably had been shielded as children and now
entered a world where they were
okay
child labor hours
and in a world now that breeds child labor and even defense child labor,
uh,
you have problems.
Market Revolution would also lead to a lot of natural environmental degradation.
People got to be got worried about rivers.
They really did.
There's now an environmental history being written sort of the impact of market
revolution and as I mentioned earlier,
it would lead of course two big cycles of boom and bust.
The big depression hit in 1837 and other big depression hitting 1857 much more
on that 1857 panic as they were called then a little later in the course because
it's absolutely pertinent to what happened in the great political debates of the
late 1850 [inaudible].
Even the idea of what a child is since we've got a child up here,
even the idea of of,
and there's a growing little sub field now of children's history,
which is actually very interesting.
There's a guy named Jim Martin and Marquette University's pioneered this.
Even the idea of a child and the child's placed in a family undergoes a kind of
revolution in 20 or 30 years in a working class family and immigrant working
class family in particular by the 30s and forties a child meant income,
a child mental worker.
Everybody had to work and usually outside of whatever it was home.
But what also said in in the growing middleclass of course was it more bourgeois
definition of childhood,
a modern definition of childhood born somewhere they're between 1,818 60 or the
child was to be a protected youth shielded and not used by a family parenting.
And this new bourgeois conception of family parenting was to be moral guardian
ship.
I saw it seemed what the market revolution was in so many ways was an engine,
a tremendous Charles Sellers has written a famous book on this was it was a
tremendous engine for what became arguably the most prevalent idea of the entire
19th century in America.
And that's the notion of progress.
America was now going to be the nation of progress.
It was going to be the place of progress.
It seems to have boundless borders and boundless resources.
It looked like it could expand almost forever.
It had tremendous riches in,
or
it had tremendous natural wealth.
It would therefore be the place of progress in the world and as Walt Whitman
road in palm after poem and other poets did as well,
and politicians said over and over and over and over America and this United
States,
this nation forum,
there would be the beginning of a new man,
a new start for him and Kai,
that's a big idea.
Of course,
we still want to be there.
It's never vanished in our culture.
We still sometimes want to be Winthrop city on the hill,
beacon of something for everybody.
But think with me just for one second about the idea of progress.
If you come to believe,
if you say to the world,
we are the hope of of humans,
we are the hope of earth,
we are progress and by the way we the people of progress or rooted in those
principles of the Declaration of independence which are written down essentially
as creeds and Olin.
By the way,
we have a written constitution.
We actually wrote it down.
We have a bill of rights where we declare these things on paper.
Unlike the Brits,
what have you done?
You said,
we are really special and we are really important and we are really good.
You kind of set yourself up having somebody walks in,
you're meeting them for the first time.
Hello,
I'm a beacon of progress and good and hope in the world.
How do you do?
You're probably going to think,
oh shit,
you know this instantly your cynicism kicks in and then who?
Who is this jerk?
The doctrine of Progress I'm simply saying is always bread.
It's contradiction.
Morale,
a whole bunch.
I'm laying out there weren't there.
We were laying all over the place,
but you know,
you couldn't resist it.
How could you resist the sense of change in 1820s,
New York,
1830s Philadelphia,
1840s and 50s,
Ohio,
1850 Chicago,
which was already by the 1850s,
a railroad capitol of,
um,
of,
uh,
of North America.
How could you resist that sense of change?
Tocqueville couldn't resist it.
It was the thing he couldn't stop writing about democracy in America and he was
only observing in 1831 he didn't come back and see it in the 1850s.
He was,
he was just amazed that these Americans,
how they just moved all the time and they were just so full of hope all the
time.
You said Americans would always build a house but then move before they put a
roof on.
They were always mobile,
always going somewhere,
always changing.
Part of that change,
of course,
bringing fear with it was immigration.
Okay.
And the 1830 600,000 immigrants came to the United States almost entirely from
western Europe.
Now,
1840s alone,
1.5 million,
and then the 1850s almost 3 million more.
Okay.
By 1852 53 Boston in New York,
think about this,
Boston,
although we're getting close to that again,
Boston and New York had 50% foreign born population.
Okay.
One of every two people in New York City in 1852 was born outside the United
States.
Same in Boston,
Costa that in Philadelphia,
the northern cities,
seats of market culture,
commercialism,
manufacturing,
were immigrant cities.
All of this of course was fueled by,
I mentioned that already a transportation revolution symbolized by the Erie
Canal,
finished an 1825 which remained profitable all the way out into the 1880s along
as a ditch in the world as it was called 300 and some odd miles out to buffalo.
Okay.
It was a romantic and by the way,
about 3,300 miles of such canals would be built by the middle of the 1850
[inaudible] all for the purpose of commerce and to move people.
Steamboats became the romantic symbol of this great transportation revolution
and all of this movement,
although they too,
they too brought dread with them.
One third of every steam boat built in the United States before 1850 exploded
and destroyed.
It became
our rec
and there's no mistaking and Mark Twain's imagination.
If you remember the scene and Huck Finn,
I mean among the hundred eternal take home images and huck Finn is that Mama.
How can Jim around their RAF?
It's a little foggy.
I can't quite see it can here.
Okay.
And pretty soon here at steamboat,
just smashes into that raft and over they go.
Steamboats were wonderful and exciting and romantic.
You could go gamble on them,
you can go get sex on him.
They also might just blow you up.
And then of course the railroads,
which reshaped North America,
no continent,
you could argue had ever been quite made,
ready made if you want for railroads quite like North America.
It fit the environment perfectly.
Once that could make these things actually go 25 miles an hour,
I never figured out how to build gauges properly.
Uh,
there was some 12 to 15 different widths of railroads and the northern states
alone by the 1850s,
you could go into one town on a gauge south,
I don't know,
three feet wide,
but on the other side of town it would come out four feet wide.
Why?
They never quite sat down and standardized all this.
I have no idea,
but railroads revolutionized an American sense of time,
their ability to travel.
It revolutionized manufacturing.
It revolutionized how quickly you could get to markets.
And I made Chicago,
Chicago.
It also made the first multimillionaires,
the first massive fortunes,
and it became the first great example of the deep relationship in the 19th
century back in our hay day of laissez faire government Ho Ho have a
relationship between the federal government and business.
The great American railroads were built by and large for decades,
but government subsidies and had tremendous amount of corruption.
Yeah,
the railroad had I been a lot to do to of course with linking northeast with
northwest,
which has a lot to do with a certain sense of economic isolation that set in in
the south to some extent.
And I'll just say a word quickly that,
that don't underestimate the influence here of an ideology beneath this.
We usually only talk about manifest destiny.
When we were talking about the western movement beyond the Mississippi,
uh,
we only usually bring it up when we're talking about the Mexican war and its
aftermath or something.
No manifest destiny was a very old American idea.
It was probably coined by this journalist's name O'sullivan,
although now there's a new theory that it wasn't no side.
I leave it to my ex,
my expert colleagues and history of the American west or decide exactly who came
up with the term manifest destiny,
who actually first used it.
But manifest destiny was in some ways the fuel of the American imagination.
It combines so many ideas.
Under that heading,
you might call American progress came the sense of American mission
spreading.
Liberty's spreading democracy,
spreading Christianity.
Uh,
Christian civilization was deeply at the root of this cluster of ideas we call
manifest destiny as was a very violent kind of nationalism that boomed after the
war of 1812 and through the 1820s into the 1830s and manifest destiny was the
engine of capitalism.
Make no mistake.
Why did we want all that land and the Mexican cession?
Why did we want Oregon?
Why did we want California and deep at the root of manifest destiny,
of course,
and his book after book written on this is a deep and abiding American white
supremacy.
It was the destiny of a white Anglo Saxon Protestant United States to take
control and improve this great land that had been given.
Not for I leave that.
Let me just suggest sometimes one of the ways when you want to understand how
progress builds builds in his own contradictions
and why I think contradiction is what makes American history interesting.
We are a,
it's why the world is fascinated with us.
Look at the literature.
Go back to all the way to James Fenimore Cooper,
his leather stockings,
tails are full of a certain anxiety about what might be happening to that
frontier.
What's coming from east to west.
Okay.
Read Thoreau's Walden.
What's the throw up?
I mean,
thorough may have been a snob.
He may have been smarmy
and he may want you to think it was cool because he's so pencils.
But he wrote one of the most brilliant critiques of change
and what it can mean.
Any American ever rode on throw sits on his little stool outside his cabin at
Walden pond and he hears the train go by over the ridge and he puts his hands
over his ears.
He doesn't want to hear it.
Okay.
He's representing something.
I'm not saying it was right.
I mean the damn fool should got down and you know,
got real with the railroads,
but
he did.
What does Emerson up to is that say nature
and almost every poem Walt Whitman wrote,
He seems to be fashioning himself,
if not the whole of this American people or sometimes he did call an American
race as a new Adam
I the singer of a Damick songs.
He said it directly through the new garden of the West,
the great cities calling as Adam early in the morning,
walking forth from the Bauer refresh with sleep.
Behold me where I pass here,
my voice,
and he goes on,
I can do anything in this American west,
this American possibility,
but as soon as we read Whitman,
then you realize there's a Nathaniel Hawthorne who in 1844 even before Whitman's
started writing most of his poems,
Hawthorne was pretty darn powerful and he was an old puritan.
It was a conservative,
dour,
doubtful kind of.
It was a real new Englander.
Hawthorne wrote a short story.
You should read some time as a balanced.
All of this optimism of this period.
Irresistible is that optimism was,
it's called Earth's Holocaust.
Have you ever read that?
It's an incredible story.
He has this whole group of people out somewhere on the American frontier and
there are kind of a cult.
They decide
they're going to have a bonfire
and they build this giant fire and intuit.
They throw everything from the past.
They throw heraldry,
they throw every kind of vestige of old world culture and monarchy,
aristocracy and civilization.
They throw all kinds of old books,
great old books under the bond.
They burn everything from Europe.
Everything that's old.
It's a purification they're gonna make and they're going to make a new world.
They don't need anything from the past.
And it's Hawthorne's satire.
It's his critique of it says apocalyptic angry,
critique it.
Oh,
these Americans who think they're inventing everything new every day.
Hawthorne had a bummer.
I mean,
well,
I guess of that.
If you want to understand the optimism of that time,
just dip into leaves of grass.
Read Whitman's o pioneers.
He can't stop.
I once kind of the number of times he used the word,
um,
the letter o in that poem and I quit counting.
It's like America to Whitman was,
oh,
he just couldn't stop.
Well and sometimes that,
oh,
America meant the tanker.
It meant the inventor.
It meant the guy who invented a new kind of sewing machine and took it in for a
pattern.
If you want to understand this Yankee northern market economy society,
just look at some histories of technological innovation throughout this era and
you realize there were just thousands and thousands of patents given mostly to
northerners for inventing this or that kind of thing or trinket or firearm or
method of producing something or printing press or glass or a musical instrument
or or Connecticut clocks or the first refrigerators or ice making machines or
new locks or new elevators and on and on and on and on and on and on.
It,
yeah,
goes,
I forget who it may have been,
Charles Sellers instead,
if you want to see the market revolution happened and go study the archives of
the U s patent office.
I've always found that kind of research road boring,
but I think he had a point
now
in any society changing this much,
this fast,
doubling its own population,
doubling in 25 years.
If the rate of population growth of the United States between 1820 and 1850 had
sustained over time,
we'd have today approximately one and a half billion people in the United
States.
No it didn't.
And we had these world wars and it all this history in between.
What do we have now?
300 million.
If the rate of growth that sustained,
that's what the population would be.
Any era of great change,
great ferment usually causes reform
anxiety.
People who get worried want to change things.
We've probably had four major periods in American history of um,
there's one of the picture I to put it up.
I don't want to leave that little girl up.
She's much better than the,
I had a picture of the Lowell Mills and Sydney,
but you don't need that.
We've had probably four great reform periods in American history.
Now I'm,
by reform I mean a period in which people became professional reformers,
movements,
organizations,
societies,
whole newspapers came into existence.
Magazines came into existence to either eradicate something,
to change something,
or to build something fundamental challenges to the social order.
The first is this era of the 1820s thirties forties and 50s antebellum America
exemplified most obviously by the antislavery movement,
which is where we're going to get to as we leave today.
Of course,
there were many other reformed movements at the time.
The second great reform era is the progressive era.
A great response to urbanization,
industrialization and immigration as it had never quite happened before.
This word is in all likelihood the new deal,
the great depression,
hey,
incredible emergencies and crises of what governments,
oh,
they're people and people owe their governments that the great depression cost
cause and the new deal brought a fundamental new set of approaches,
ideas,
which we're still debating today.
It's all over our political culture,
whether it's named or not,
and the fourth one is the 60s
there it had less to do often was social forms of reform,
although that's not entirely true.
Then it had to do with the civil rights revolution and the Vietnam War
in American history are reform.
Crusades have usually had to do with one of several objects or purposes or
problems.
The first is the industrializing process and we've been living the,
the,
the history of how to reform the industrializing process and now the post
industrializing process.
Ever since our first market revolution,
we're still living it.
Why are we having a debate over social security?
The second is racial equality and we're still having that reform movement.
Well,
or are we,
the third is gender equality.
That's at least as old as abolitionism.
The fourth is war.
We've got peace movements in American history and anti war fervor and ferment of
all kinds for a very long time.
And the fifth kind of American reform,
and it's here,
it takes on sometimes some distinctive distinctly American forms
is religious and individual morality.
Movements of piety.
Okay.
Movements that try to define deviants and others and try to reform others to a
certain personal conception of faith or religion or behavior.
But whenever we've had a reform era,
there's been a big issue or two or three or four.
That's why all these arguments that we all get into these days about third party
political candidates,
uh,
you know,
what do we really need in our political culture?
What would break apart the stagnation of our two party system if that's what
people want or put more directly,
we'll Michael Bloomberg run or not.
I always throw that back at people and say,
dammit,
read some history.
Okay.
There's never been a successful third party political culture take hold in this
country without one really big issue to drive it.
Name that issue that Michael Bloomberg Bloomberg would use.
I'm a billionaire and you can be too.
That's unfair.
I know he's a nice guy.
Well,
let me just end here.
Uh,
with this
to be anti slavery in America by the 1820s and 1830s
what's the face a host of barriers,
and I'll come back to these barriers next time.
A host of barriers,
the sanctity of the u s constitution,
the depth of that pro slavery argument,
which America was northern abolitionist overtime had to actually come to to
realize even existed and they began to realize it existed in the agent twenties
and thirties
they faced tremendous barriers.
There was no good reason in the world that an abolitionist and the 1830s forties
even 50s had any right to believe.
They would see the end of slavery in their lifetime.
And last point,
one of the barriers,
I think about this,
one of the barriers that an anti slavery,
you know,
a few were you were worried about slavery in America.
It's expansion.
It's influencing the government,
what it did to free labor,
how it might retard that market revolution that you wanted your children to
benefit from.
Whatever position you might end up taking between 1830 in 1860 that made you at
least suspicious of slavery.
Whatever you thought of African Americans,
one of the barriers you're up against is the simple fact that the United States
was a republic,
and that the side that own those slaves,
that vast slave society,
half of the United States,
it's still half the states in 1850
they were free.
Their leaders,
at least we're free to defend their system.
They were free to dissent.
They were Republicans.
Smaller too.
The greatest tragedy of America,
of American history,
arguably,
is that this struggle could not be decided by debate.
Okay?
See you in the gym.